silence is not at all a sign of
callousness
only what is empty on the inside rattles
love all trust a few
do wrong to none
have more than you show
speak less than you know
there is nothing good or bad in this
world
there is only our attitude toward
anything
go wisely and slowly
those who Rush stumble and fall
for sweetest things turn sourest by
their deeds
lilies that Fester smell far worse than
weeds
a fool thinks he is wise
but a wise man knows he is a fool
we know what we are
but not what we may be
expectation is the root of all heartache
look like an innocent flower
but be the serpent under it
so sweet is the honey
bad at last it is bitter
excess of flavor kills the taste
the Grayton Act
as you have been in thought
all's well that ends well
better a witty fool
than a foolish wit
where words are few
they have their weight
men of few words are the best men
to be or not to be
that is the question
vows made in a storm are forgotten in
calm weather
in striving for the best
we often spoil the good we have
our doubts are our traitors
they make us lose what we could probably
win if we weren't afraid to try
every obstacle to love only strengthens
it
what's done
cannot be undone
fear is the ever-present companion of
untruth
God hath given you one face
and you make yourself another
the coward dies at every danger that
threatens him
but the brave man dies only once
it's easy for someone to joke about
scars
if they've never been cut
brevity is the soul of wit
not all that Glitters Is Gold
so often we are reminded
for many have lived and in the end their
tomb of gold keeps worms inside
the hope of pleasure is almost as
pleasurable as pleasure itself
conscience doth make cowards of us all
the more cowardly a person is
the less he values himself
even a bloody crime does not reveal
itself so soon
as a love that wishes to be hidden
with mirth and laughter
let old wrinkles come
reputation is an idol and most false
imposition
often god without Merit and lost without
deserving
you are so eager to judge the sins of
others
start with your own
and you won't get to other people's
self-love is not as deserving of
condemnation as a lack of self-respect
there are no tricks in plain and simple
faith
the more attractive a woman is the less
she has the chance to have a true love
and the more she is likely to live with
a broken heart
some are born great
others achieve greatness
if there is a good will
there is great way
Don't Waste Your Love on somebody who
doesn't value it
if we are true to ourselves
we cannot be false to anyone
false face must hide
with a false heart doth no
all the world's a stage
and all the men and women are merely
players